an item of news nfl media agent on
record with nfl media antonio brown
re-signing with the buccaneers
reportedly 3.1 million dollar deal that
can be worth up to 6.25 million you
always wonder what the up to terms are
super bowl mvp sometimes is one of the
triggers to get the full compensation
but brown is back so the band
entirely back together into amazing
settling selling that lawsuit last week
i know jason light tried to downplay it
i say bullpucky to that
the lawsuit was everything because if
that lawsuit doesn't go away he
testifies under oath at some point it's
potentially a disaster
and uh that he that thing needed to go
away before they were going to resign
him i believe and now that it's gone
they resign him fans entirely back
together for 2021 yeah it's hard to
believe that that wouldn't be part of
the conversation and i mean it just it
looks too i mean it can't be that
coincidental you know yeah that got
solved then dialogue started to ha you
know go go through a contract talk there
and now here we are a few days through
the dialogue they got them back so i
mean i think you were spot on with the
fact in your reading with what jason
light said and all that type of stuff
but it's amazing to bring the band back
in full totality uh again i don't think
we've ever seen it it's it's truly
special uh but jason light bruce arians
what they got going there in tampa and
you know i don't know mike what do you
think antonio brown you think he had any
other suitors out there i mean the looks
of that contract tell me that
he really didn't and this was just like
hey we like you and maybe we'll throw
you a little bit more change than
you know we have to because our
quarterback likes you and we like what
you did for our team last year
last year it was the minimum this year
it's 3.1 million so that's a nice little
bump and and that opportunity to double
it more than double at 6.25 i i look i i
believe
from what i've heard
that even though russell wilson
had been stumping for brown to go to the
seahawks the seahawks
did their homework back in 2019 when
they first started to really focus on
josh gordon didn't want antonio brown
ravens didn't want antonio brown and and
there's a an argument to be made that
lamar jackson and hollywood brown
antonio's cousin were just being tactful
and deferential sure older player and
they really didn't want him either that
that and and and the ravens offered up
dez bryant as the compromise why would
hollywood want him to brown why would
like hot like hollywood couldn't get the
ball himself he was mad at that what do
you want antonio his cousin to come in
and steal some of them so i'm with you i
don't know if that was like that was
more i i hey let's give respect to a
legend and we'd love to have him here
kind of talk i i kind of agree with you
there on that takes and i remember
explaining at the time the possibility
first came up the ravens should not want
antonio there because when it goes
sideways and it always does
then he's going to poison hollywood
against the ravens and there goes your
chance of keeping him around long term
if you've got antonio constantly saying
what a bunch of jerks they are so uh
anyway that's where that stands antonio
brown back with the buccaneers all the
free agents back under contract and now
they get to select a whole new crop of
incoming rookies on thursday friday and
saturday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports